[Music]
so Doug happy to have you here today
super nice to meet you really look
forward to getting into this
conversation you got an incredible story
but setting aside jail recovery drug
addiction all of my favorite subjects
perhaps your greatest achievement is
that you got Amy Dresner interested in
fitness I don't know how you did that
that's like a miracle so you got some
kind of gift well I mean when I first
reached out to Amy to interview her for
my new book and I was talking to her
about working out and I just saw that
she was something man you're so skinny I
was like if you ever write X you ever
worked out before and she was like yeah
back in the day here and there and you
know I finally I was like well here do
these exercises I gave her like some
stuff to do in our owns up some foods to
eat and she like didn't do it I was like
you know what I'm just gonna train you
so you know we kind of helped each other
out you know she would help me cuz I
didn't know a lot of people in since I
didn't get sober in the 12 steps I
didn't know a lot of people who were in
recovery like it would be open to
interviewing for my book so I just say
if you can help me like you know reach
out to some people because I just I just
don't know right and I'll help you out
with your workouts and that's kind of
how it started and you know she's just
she's just like everybody she wanted to
see results like instantaneously of
course and I told her I said listen you
got to be patient it's gonna take time I
think about how long even beaten up your
body you know physically not really
doing anything and you know she actually
started seeing some results like
mentally first she really started
feeling better about herself she really
started you know noticing the importance
of being dedicated to something and then
at first it from it being a daunting
task of her working out she was texting
me can we work out today can we work
I was like look I'm getting some curves
and I'm like and it's fun too because we
have fun I mean we do it on skype and
she's the most uncoordinated person
you'll ever meet she's like falling out
of screen and she'll be the first to
tell you that and she like you know drop
the dumbbell on her forehead the other
day like trying to do a skull crusher
and I was like I've never seen anybody
do that before so it's it's I got to
tell you it's been fun
well she's refreshingly self-deprecating
and I love her I think she's just
amazing but when I had her on the
podcast which was a little over a year
ago at this point I would not have you
know pegged her as somebody who was
gonna be getting like obsessed with
getting fit all of a sudden so it's
super cool that that's on that that's
the path that she's non-right and you're
the you're the catalyst for that yeah
it's been a it's been a blessed thing I
mean as a trainer people always ask me
like what the what makes me feel good as
a trainer and the physical benefits
helping somebody lose weight or run
faster and get stronger it's definitely
good but just watching somebody see that
the the the the mental aspect and the
emotional component of it and especially
people in recovery because I really
think that fitness and nutrition or two
of the most underutilized tools in
recovery and and so Amy to be able to
see that and now write a piece about it
it's just been something that I'm just
really humbled that I was a living part
in that story
yeah it's cool she just wrote this
article that came out on the fix that
you're a big part of and I'm sort of
quoted in and Mischka yeah have you met
Mishka not in purchase through emailed
as you go - yeah but I think you're
right you know I'm somebody who I know
that you're you got sober outside of
12-step you know 12-step just like you
know with Amy you know no I'm a 12-step
person it's how I got sober and it's
still you know the number one thing in
my life super important but there's
plenty of truth in this idea that
there's space for trying to build in
healthy lifestyle habits and you know I
don't know if it's an additional step
but you know there's a lot of smoking
cigarettes and drinking too much coffee
and you know a lot of cupcakes and and
donuts going on there and and I think
you know it would behoove the community
to embrace a you know a healthier way
of eating and living and moving as part
of that program of becoming more
integrated and whole yeah I mean just I
mean as somebody who did get sober I
said that 12 steps I have the most
respect for it for them and I but you
know I think outside of that you're
right I think there is some some room
for fitness and for nutrition and I
think as people you know once they they
stop you know using the drugs and the
alcohol to deal with you know
insecurities and stress and whatever I
mean they got to replace it with
something or something else and not
enough not so much in a addictive way
but just in a mindfulness way and being
able to to exercise and just building
that you know dedication and the ability
to achieve goals I think correlates in
their recovery as well do people say to
you that you've transferred your
addiction on to fitness I mean though
because I mean I mean I guess now I'm at
a point where I mean I only probably
work out maybe 45 minutes to an hour a
day five days a week and I make sure to
take the time to rest and make sure to
take the time to enjoy myself I mean you
know I guess I can definitely see where
I can write if I was working out 3 4 or
5 hours a day with no and go like for no
reason if I wasn't training for anything
crazy to work out for 5 hours walking on
a treadmill a day then yeah but I mean
nobody's really ever said that to me
because there's other there's other
parts of my recovery like with some of
the people I hang out with and my
spirituality and and helping other
people that Fitness isn't just it I
don't think you can just do push-ups and
sit-ups and never use again I just think
fitness and was the catalyst to getting
me into recovery and then help me along
the way to meet these other things other
people in my life that have kind of
helped me get to where I am now yeah
that's an important point i mean i you
know i said this i shared amy's article
with the caveat or not the caveat but
just the sort of explainer that for me
you know fitness is a huge component of
my recovery program but it's not a
replacement for my higher power it is
not it is not my recovery program you
know in its complete sense it's just an
aspect of it and i've gotten into
trouble in the past and I've seen other
people get into trouble in the past when
they put Fitness above everything and
think that that is the solution to what
ails them at the expense of everything
else and that is not I mean it's just
speaking from my own personal experience
like that's not a tenable path no and I
kind of to be honest you know I at first
thought you know when I got a jail that
I could just run and do push-ups and to
enlightenment right and then I hit a
plug and then and then I hit a point and
I was like hmm like I look really good I
feel really good I'm doing like I have a
great job but I'm still not fulfilled
and there was that point there was that
part of me that was that spiritual
component that came in that I ended up
you know developing a relationship with
God cuz I didn't have any relationship
with anything and then also like the
importance of having mentors in my life
people that have been have been through
life either in the business world or in
the in the personal development world
it's kind of like almost like my sponsor
so if I'm having like a bad day or if I
got a business thing or that's or I mean
that I need to bounce an idea off of I
have them the call it's not like I'm
just like put my head down and trying to
do it myself I mean it's I mean for a
while the first few years
yeah the ego got in the way but then I
got humbled really quick and was like
boy you better like learn to include
some other aspects into this or it's
gonna be a really long road for you yeah
so who are those mentors for you I mean
I got to say my grandparents first and
foremost because when I got out of jail
they took me in let me stay with them so
I mean they they are some people I
communicate with everywhere were your
folks and the whole equation so I mean
my my parents and I kind of had a torn
relationship as a kid you know I was
kicked out of my mom's house when I was
16 because I was you know running around
smoking pot and acting like a little
devil child and um and then my dad and I
kind of always had a we always butted
heads with each other and kind of it was
just kind of like I just kind of burned
every Bridge at the point and my
grandparents had just said you know what
like we'll take you in under these
certain stipulations I had to have a job
I had to bring him receipts for where I
was going I got to be had to be in a
certain time like certain accountability
that I never wanted to follow in my life
for some reason I just was like you know
what like I need to do it now so where
are you at with your
folks now my mom and I have okay like a
really really good relationship way
better even than when I was a kid like
we've kind of both come to terms with
the things that happened when I was
younger and my dad and I we kind of mean
it's a family can be kind of tricky
sometimes and you know we will talk here
and there but I just kind of it's hard
you know for me because he's my dad but
I know hopefully one day if it's
intended to it'll work out but right now
we we talk when we can slow variety yeah
slow bride yeah I feel you it is it's
tricky Matt but time time has a way of
healing these things yeah absolutely
well let's track it back create a little
context here so paint me the picture of
your wayward youth so I mean growing up
my parents got divorced when I was five
and I was always the kid that was super
like I love being active I love playing
sports my friends I love you know
playing like recreational sports but I
was just like the most terrible athlete
ever I couldn't run I couldn't jump and
I could hardly balance myself and so I
was always like the one of the last ones
picked uh-huh I was always like the slow
one and so and and on top of that I was
eating very poor like I mean like lunch
or dinner I was obsessed with like pasta
and I would eat like pasta and butter
for dinner I already like cinnamon buns
and like sausage for breakfast and
genetics didn't bless me with having one
of those faster metabolism so it caught
up to me real quick but so when I was 12
I started gaining weight and 10 to 12
years old I was like a little heavier
than most kids and I started getting
depressed cuz I had this divorce and I
had these insecurities and I'm now being
depressed like depressed and then I my
luck with women wasn't very good and
then by the time I was 14 I just was
looking for a way out and I got offered
a hit off a marijuana pipe and I felt
like this monkey come off my back like I
could be myself again I could be secure
and who I was I didn't have to worry
about any problems I had in my life and
then it just like we all know snowballs
and the next thing and I'm selling it to
support my habit and then I'm barely
graduating high school because I didn't
go to school as much as I should because
I was skipping the smoke and started
experimenting with coke let's slow it
down man
plenty to play we got time I want to
understand this a little bit better so
start smoking pot of 14 and and walk me
through the path from you know that
first hit to like now I'm gonna start
dealing like I'm selling this well so I
was super lazy as a kid and so when I
started smoking pot I was like oh my
gosh I love this I need to do whatever I
need to do to get more of it that light
like the light switch just went on it
was this is for me it is the answer to
every problem I've ever knew that I had
anything that any like you know
insecurities stress anxiety like
anything was gone after I smoked pot I
just felt I felt at ease and so I just
started meeting people and asking them
where I could buy more pot and then the
more I realized I loved it I was like
hmm well me making $6 an hour here
washing dishes I can't afford to buy as
much pot as I need to so I'm gonna start
selling it to support my habit that's
what ultimately led to me getting kicked
out of my mom's house when I was 16 I
had a party when she was in the hospital
like slopes like right before my 16th
birthday to try to fit in with kids cuz
that was like the thing you did in high
school was yet parties when your parents
were away well my parents didn't go away
so I I left the bottom window unlocked
and snuck back in after she went in the
hospital and cops came to my townhouse
and I thought it was a good idea to run
you know for my own party you know an
hour later I'm getting these calls my
neighbors and family like where are you
get back Aaron they're back I went and
and then it was about a few weeks later
on my 16th birthday I was I was weighing
out a little bit of pot to sell it on
one of my neighbors and told my brother
I said watch him watch the door my mom
and come in and and she whip and she
walks and you know that was it you know
the next day I was kicked I was kicked
out of her house that day that next day
I switched high schools went from
Delaney high school which was a pretty
prep your high school to up in the
country where my dad lived to North
Harford it was like
they drive your tractor to school day
and the people who went there they
called him duck farmers like select
north of Baltimore yeah it was like
Harford County so probably like from
Baltimore City was probably like about
an hour hour north up towards the
Pennsylvania line and it was a huge huge
humbling experience for me and I guess
they thought that it would you know to
kind of take me away from the drugs but
I mean right so your parents deal with
this in the way that they deal with it
but I would imagine you would say
irrespective of how they chose to handle
it like you were gonna be an addict like
this was the path for you no matter what
is that fair yeah with that light switch
going on like that I mean I guess what
I'm getting at what I'm interested in
hearing is given that there's a lot of
for apparent age people that listen to
this podcast and being a parent myself
I'm interested in like what is the
there's the knee-jerk parental reaction
like oh my god you know what's
catastrophize this versus what is the
healthier response like how can you be
loving and compassionate and
understanding but also firm and and not
codependent when confronted with a
situation like that well I mean I think
with them they just don't really know
how to handle it they didn't understand
it I mean it wasn't as you know back
then I'm talking you know 15 years ago I
mean it's so much more out and about now
that they they probably my mom probably
just did the best she could I mean she
didn't know what to do she couldn't take
the stress I found out years later that
she had multiple sclerosis and stress
with that obviously doesn't doesn't mend
well and you know I guess the I hate
always years later I've ever say to my
mom a few years ago I said I wish you
would have looked at why I was doing
drugs not the fact that I was because I
had a lot of depression from the divorce
I was being picked on at school my
athletic ability was terrible and I had
a huge passion for sport so I was
watching all these kids that were really
really good at sports and I was always
the kid that never made the teams and
just looked on the sidelines being like
man like why not me right and it's just
unfortunately I do a big downfall for me
yeah yeah it's hard to
know what to look for and it's like it
when you look in the rearview mirror
it's very clear right oh here it all
lined up perfectly for its unfolded in
this way but when you're in the mitt in
the moment of you know you have to be
hyper present and aware to see those
signals I think yeah I mean in I think
they were still unpacking stuff from the
divorce because the divorce was pretty
it was rough it would that mean they
weren't communicating hardly with each
other only via email and there was child
support there out there yeah custody and
child support so I mean they they they
were battling their their own things you
know and I think you know having me make
the choices I may just add fuel to the
fire and they were like you know what
like I've tried to talk to you and just
get out and it it was at a point in my
life you know that I was 16 and I was
going through I was maturing as a man
and being about my mom because obviously
you know when things don't go your way
there was a violent like fight like not
physical but like yelling at each other
I said some things I would never imagine
saying ever again to her and it just it
crushed me because my mom I needed my
mom and that time I was struggling the
most at that time in my life and I just
really wish you know I hindsight's 2020
because our relationship right now I
mean it changed forever
being that you know there was a point
where I wasn't allowed to live with her
anymore I wasn't a lot in her house
did it change directory directory of our
relationship forever and it's just now
being able to talk to her openly and be
like mom like you're my mom and I love
you but I can't say I have the same
emotional connection that other people
do with their moms because of so because
of the choices that I made and that we
both made and where life took us and
it's it's sad but now we've both gotten
to the point where we can talk to each
other openly about it which we never
really had I mean it would took gosh you
know five six seven years for for her to
really come around and really be able to
talk to me about it and if agree that
but that honesty is a is a British to
you know greater intimacy it may not be
you know the intimacy that you see in
movies like older son relationship but
you know the most intimate that it can
be given
circumstances what do you what do you
make of this current embrace of
marijuana that we're seeing in our
culture right now like it's super
interesting times because for the most
part it's essentially legal and it's
super easy to get I mean especially here
in California it's ubiquitous there is
this kind of weird idea that's floating
around out there that like pot is kind
of part of the wellness world like a
medium and and the use is so profligate
that it see it comes off as at worst
benign but perhaps a performance
enhancer for certain people right and
there are a lot of people out there that
kind of use it all day long every day
and they seem fine and yet you're
somebody who you know for better or
worse Pot was like a gateway drug and
it's like you like it's almost laughable
like how pots a gateway drug hahaha like
it's that's so not true but in your case
that really was true it was and I get
asked a lot too about it and they're
like I just say just obviously just like
anything else depends on the purse and
I'm not you know I'm not for
recreational marijuana I mean obviously
they argument is well alcohol is legal
well I mean yeah it is but it doesn't
make it right and and pot was a gateway
drug for me because I couldn't smoke
enough pot to get high anymore I
couldn't it was a point where it stopped
working for me I developed some sincere
paranoia just cuz it just stopped
working and I could only I mean I was
smoking like 1/4 ounce of pot a day and
for those listening who ever smoked pot
that's a lot of pot it's not like I was
just taking smoking and joy in a day and
so that led to me one new experiment
with other things not only experiment
but meet other people because once you
get into the game of you're starting to
sell pot and you're starting to do more
things you start to meet people with
harder drugs and more people doing it
and that's what led me ultimately to try
something else is going to alter my mind
and cocaine and then I learned cocaine
and anxiety don't go well it's like the
worst possible thing and then if you're
starting to getting paranoid on on pot
to move to cocaine is gonna
so but here's the thing and here's the
other thing that I it's like more of
like a lifestyle thing with the pot like
it's like you ride around with your
friends and you smoke pot and you're
listening to this or listen to that and
I couldn't give that up so much to the
point where that's what started my my
opiate habit was that I couldn't smoke
pot anymore with my friends because I
was getting crazy anxiety attacks I was
like I wouldn't be able to drive my
friends were like laughing at me because
I had no idea what was going on but you
know I hadn't have any anxiety and I got
offered a five milligram percocet one
day and I was able again that same
monkey that came off my back when I was
started smoking pot was the same monkey
that came off my back when I took that
five milligram percocet I could get high
again without having a panic attack and
it was I couldn't give up smoking weed
so that's the other thing it's like you
build this community of people you get
high with and you smoke weed with it's
probably just as hard to let go of you
know aside from giving up pot if you're
somebody that it's you know impeding
your life or you're struggling with it
and a lot of people don't think about
that yeah so where does the percocet
take you oh I mean literally down the
highway to hell I mean once I realized
how much that could help me continue to
smoke weed I also realized how much it
would numb the pain of me being at a
point where I'm you know 18 19 20 years
old and really disappointed in myself
because I was a smart kid I wanted to be
like an accountant there was times I
wanted to be a lawyer I want to be in
the FBI like I had some big aspirations
as a kid but you know I I lost a few
friends to drinking and driving
accidents when I was in my when I was
younger and so I just thought I was
going to die by the time I was 25 I just
was like well it doesn't matter and so
each time I would get high I would just
it would numb the pain and I didn't
really understand I mean I knew
obviously I wasn't putting kale in my
system that I didn't but I didn't
realize how addictive this stuff was
yeah you know and I thought well I'm not
doing heroin so it's okay and and that
was just my way of just making it seem
like it's okay those goal posts are
always moving yeah I started doing
heroin it would be like well snorting
again unless you yeah or yeah I'm doing
it but you know I don't live in a
flophouse or you know whatever it is
like I'm not
I don't have you know abscesses in my
arm so I'm okay yeah and then so the
five the five milligrams turn into me
being I need a new ten to get high
twenty and forty and then to the point
where I was you know buying the oxy 80
milligrams and we were getting them from
a guy who had cancer and was giving them
to uh you know and it was just that the
thing you know we were looking at I'm
release off and I had like blue dye and
red dot and orange stuff all over my
t-shirts and got to the point where I
was spending several hundred hours a day
on opiates and doing some really bad
things with my judgment that you know
and I just burned a lot of bridges with
with people and I just developed a new
group of friends that you weren't my
friend unless you were getting high with
me or you could lead me to getting high
and it was just it was bad I mean I was
I mean half my left nose my nostril was
missing just from putting so much crap
up there and so you're snorting oxy yeah
grind it up to over override the
time-release aspect of it oh yeah and I
know wouldn't do anything unless it was
like pure oxy cotton like Cotto you know
word it and where were you getting at
just from connections I had made from
the from the drug world or you know I
had friend a friend that worked at a
pharmacy and then I had somebody that
you know that knew somebody who had
cancer and you know there's obviously a
huge market in that and they were a lot
cheaper and they are now I mean now like
the street value I think like doubled
since since I was doing anything you get
like an 80 milligram oxy cotton pill for
like 40 50 bucks and now it's way more
than that from when I and how would you
for somebody who's never taken that or
has never done opiates like explain the
feeling of you know a day on oxy like
what is it you know what is it doing for
you like what you know this is I mean
I'm this is an epidemic yeah there are
millions of people that are hooked on
hillbilly heroin it's a gigantic problem
so you know what's the allure I mean
you'd be riding around with your friends
or with your friends looking like almost
like it's another high learning how
you're gonna score drugs for the day
and then you couldn't really cuz you
don't have any appetite because you're
half withdrawing without having at it
you know once you finally did figure out
who had the best deal or you could con
to get them you get them you
you know like I said we would lick the
time-release is off we crush him up on a
DVD case like always snored him with a
hundred dollar bill I was like oh and
off a blow DVD case you know that was
the waited the cool thing you do right
right and and then we would go eat and
like a meal for me like would be like a
cheese steak and two slices of pizza and
french fries and and then we would like
you know sit on the couch and like just
like talk about dumb stuff all day at
like times man yeah like veg out like
watch like you know like The Wizard of
Oz or something you know create
something you know or watch just movies
and I mean nothing really productive
play xbox by FIFA soccer I mean we did a
lot of playing Fifa and you let your
life gets really small it does you don't
realize how small it gets you think
that's it you think that that life isn't
gonna get any better and you you don't
realize that you don't have to go get
high before you go to a football game or
you don't realize you don't have to go
get high before going to dinner with
your mom and you know you don't you
don't realize like what you're doing and
how other people kind of see that
whether they're judging you or not but
you're just all of a sudden think that
like what you're doing is like it's okay
and you're once you get out of it you're
like I can't believe I did that stuff
was there an awareness that you had a
problem or did you just think I can stop
at any time for a while I didn't I
really didn't think I had a problem I
mean I mean I knew what I was doing
wasn't wasn't right but I mean we were
that's all my friends and I did so like
my community around me that's what we
did so it's it's a so it was like a norm
it was a normal thing it wasn't really
until I started really not being able to
get out of bed when I was you know got
myself above the 100 50 milligram a day
habit that I was like damn I can't get
out of bed without like feeling awful
that something's gotta something's gotta
give and then when I would try to like
you know withdrawal a detox on my own I
would think about everything again like
my life would come up all the choices I
made and all the the people I'd you know
pissed off and where I was headed and
and then the stress of selling drugs
that I was like well I can't comfortable
my own skin I gotta find a way to get
more drugs no matter what and you know
how
just got the pain of that tidal wave of
emotions and shame and guilt and anxiety
and depressed
toppling down on you so hard that it's
an you have to go back I think that's
what a lot of people don't understand
about the cycle of addiction you have
this well-intentioned desire you
understand like can't live like this
anymore
and you take a stab at trying to get
better and then the minute you start to
experience that the pain the emotional
pain of it is so severe that you're just
like [ __ ] it I gotta go back yeah I mean
I know a lot of people think that people
like want to be addicted to drugs and
it's like I don't think anybody want
wants to I mean who wants to live a life
like that I mean and you know everybody
wants to get well and they have the
intentions of doing so but like they
don't just don't think they can or they
don't know how to or they've just had so
much trauma in their life that they have
no confidence in themselves at all of it
they don't even like believe that they
can go two hours without it it's really
sad so this whole house of cards comes
toppling down on you yeah you share that
aspect of the journey yes oh you know
you're not exactly the brightest person
when you're you know putting copious
amounts of drugs up your nose and my
friend's parents this money you know as
I had torn relationships with my family
growing up my friend's parents like kind
of like filled in we're always kind of
there for me you know even though we're
I didn't have a place to stay because I
didn't want to abide by rules or whatnot
I would sleep on couches and my one
friends dad was like Doug you're riding
around with everybody knew what I was
doing they knew I was riding around
selling a bunch of pot they knew I was
like you know the do goofball thinks
snorting oxy and they're like you better
change your headlight they're like
that's like a red flag to get pulled
over by a cop yeah and you know of
course I was like the king of being the
king of procrastination and I never did
it and Cinco de Maya 2008 I'm riding
around with a few of my friends to go
pick up some oxycontin I had a half a
pound of pot in my trunk hidden and
where the spare tire I was thinking
don't worry no one will ever find it
here like he and I had a bunch of cash
and
all of a sudden am i coming and there's
a cop coming like on the opposite hearse
riding radar on the opposite side and I
flashed my high beams at him thinking
that it would like you know hide the
fact that I didn't have a headlight made
of course it gave him a reason to pull
me over he's like why is this guy high
up high be me on Cinco de Maya which of
course I did completely forgot was I one
of the biggest drinking holidays of the
year and it's like you know any excuse
to pull you over yeah so he pulls me
over and it's me and two of my friends
my heart's racing I'm like holy crap
like I just had this gut feeling that
like this was it like I'm done like I
just had a feeling something was gonna
happen and I was I have all this stuff
in my car what do i do where am I gonna
hide it the conflict approaches my
window
you know asks me to put my window down
what should happen before I've been
pulled over before and luckily didn't
get caught but this was different and
felt different to me and all of a sudden
one of my friends in the backseat had an
open container of Beria's drinking and
because I the smell of alcohol was like
wafting out the car you know he's
drinking like a gnat it like a natty
light or something right and he wouldn't
give up to get the cop was like I smell
beer and uh and the guy my friend ended
up like not really at first rely
languishing the can of beer and I was
like to just give it like he might let
us just go trying to hide it because I
was only twenty years old we were all we
were all and you know and and so he ends
up he ends up giving it to him and you
know then he asked me more questions
he's like do I have the right to sir
he's like I give me a reason to believe
that you know you have some illegal
stuff in here do I have the right to
search your car for some reason I said
yes go ahead he's a guard come out of
the car and you know hindsight's always
20/20 if I'd said no what would happen
but I mean you need to hear it over
there and I said yes he pulls me out of
the car okay well they're never gonna
find the pots and the spare tire and now
comes the pot and all the money and like
my heart is was already racing it was
like racing like twice as fast like
crying I was thinking about all the
negative choices and all the things that
have happened that I'm the choices I
made and everything that had happened to
me they come to that but it all came to
that came to a point and I was I'm
sitting in the back
hop car and I just didn't think I was
gonna make it rich I got to tell you
like I thought that was it I thought I
was gonna either spend the rest of my
life incarcerated or just kill my
something mean something bad I thought
was gonna really happen ended up being
the biggest blessing of my life
well I would submit to you and I'm sure
you've thought about this but perhaps on
some level albeit maybe an unconscious
level you wanted to get caught because
if you had people saying look man you
got to change your light out yeah you
can chalk that up to laziness but the
fact that you didn't get your headlight
fixed you turned a blind eye to the fact
that it was Cinco DeMayo and when the
cop asked you if he could search your
car you said sure fine
like there's something inside of you I
think that was trying to save yourself
by getting caught yep right you're
probably right I mean I I just I had no
other way out there was no other way out
I knew I was gonna get to a point where
I was either dead in jail or a
combination of both because my friends
and I always like joked around and we
weren't gonna like what's the point of
like living past 30 if we can't like
party hard anymore right and so I just
was like I was I've come to that
realization that that was gonna be my
life and then I'm ever getting going to
jail and you spend that night in jail
that was it's awful right because you're
like I'm like high on opiates but had
gotten the next high that I wanted so it
was like a total buzzkill
like it's like to the like fullest
extent and then so I put like seventy
thousand miles in that car got pulled
over and he's selling drugs and I was
also a delivery boy so it gave me any
two different pizzas
yeah so gave me an excuse to like ride
around and you know a couple buddies and
I worked at the same pizza shop so we
would park our car like a Burger King
we'd all ride together and go on like a
high ride and smoke weed together and
you know pinch off like french fries
here and there out of people's foods and
and so but I put seventy thousand miles
on my car and so a few weeks later after
I got arrested I didn't change my oil
when I was driving on 695 and my car
like blew up like it's just started
smoking because it just died Road
and oh my god man so it's my Grandpere
well it's submit yeah it's a metaphor
just like trut you know just like ride
it hard until it's but if the whole
thing just blows up in your face yeah
and my grandparents talked about and
they're like silly not silly choice but
it was almost like I did I did I almost
wanted to make was you know we met with
uh I mean I got charged the felony the
intended should be marijuana and you
know possession of paraphernalia and
stuff and I did the only one that really
mattered was when I got arranged for the
felony charge and my grandparents were
like alright we'll give you money for to
pay for a lawyer or to get you a car and
I was like well if I don't have a car I
can't do drugs or sell drugs right and I
was in the whole genius and I was in the
whole five grand of a drug dealer so cuz
when I got busted I was already like
leading up to my arrest like I had been
robbed somebody like ripped me off like
a half a pound of pot and I was in the
hole a couple thousand to him already
and I was trying I was literally done I
were going to my grandparents and we
were just talking about this I said I'm
done selling drugs I was like can you
please just lend me the money to pay
this guy off and be done with it and
they said no we're not we're not funding
like in a like a criminal activity for
you I find it kind of charming though
that you're honest with your
grandparents like I'm selling drugs and
I'm in trouble can you help you're
talking about this recently and I was it
was almost like the biggest blessing
because if they did it would just give
it I don't who knows where I would be
now and and so when I owed this guy 5
grand I ended up you know getting like a
Geo Prizm or something that was like the
driver door ended up like breaking so I
had to like Dukes of Hazard it to get in
every time it was like the awful most
awful thing to pick up a a date in but
so I would this guy five grand and he
was obviously after me for $5,000 not
like I owed him like $20.00 and my
brother actually ran into one of my
roommates at one of the local bars and
my roommate had told him what was going
on and my brother called me and was like
hey man like I heard what happened and I
heard you of this guy money he's like I
want to give it
it's like a hot man don't you know one
get yourself involved in that and he's
like no I want to I was like all right
and so we have you met at the bank he
gave me pulled out five grand in cash he
was one of my brothers a couple years
younger than mean he was always a kid
who like saved all his money I spent all
my money he saved all his and I'm eating
this this drug dealer had a we were at
like Outback or Carabas a restaurant
like that and I just gave him the money
and I just said listen man I'm done and
I thought that would close a chapter in
me and not being in debt to my not being
in debt and working I'll pay my brothers
back my brother back but you know one
thing led to the next and I'm gonna
borrow more money to get high and borrow
more money and borrow more money and to
the point where now I'm I've owed him my
brother owned like nearly ten thousand
dollars for four drugs in lying about
what I needed it for and and so
September I got arrested in May and this
kind of all transpired with paying my
drug dealer off you know in the months
to follow and a September I went to
court and I've hi in court I had I was
supposed to like you know they were like
you better like pass some drug tests
like before you come the show you've
been like clean and they didn't do that
so you did you stopped a public defender
yo so my dad had like a he knew like a
guy who was like a general attorney he
wasn't like any high high power attorney
or anything but I guess just somebody
there was kind of like just to be there
with me uh-huh and I had no idea what to
expect all the lawyers I had talked to
were like you're gonna you definitely do
in jail time it was my first offense but
they're like here in Harford County
which is like a super conservative
County and they're like you had like a
lot of pot and they found a scale and
you admitted that you had drugs like
that you admitted that everything in
your car was yours so and your lawyer
didn't say listen man you got a at least
post up at some a meetings and get a
core card signed and so you can show the
judge that you're trying to mend your
ways I think they had said something
like that I'm a ride walk I just didn't
didn't matter
and I got to I got to court and the
judge looked at me and he was like you
know you'd ask me serious question
there's cross-examining me and I'm just
obviously I admitted everything and the
lawyer had said hey we've kind of made a
deal with him that he's gonna give you
the maximum sentence but I think you're
gonna like what he has to say and I was
like maximum sentence and and so he
looks at me he's like Doug you know I
find you you know guilty of felony the
felony drug charge intent to distribute
marijuana and he dropped dropped the
other stuff but he said I'm gonna send
in two to five years suspended
everything but 90 days meaning I just
had to do the 90 day jail sentence and I
was backing up to five five years
probation 200 hours community service
all kinds of drug classes and fines and
he's like Doug and then I had to abide
by the rules of parole and probation
he's like but if you complete everything
without messing up after the five years
is up I'll take the felony off your
record and I remember looking in court I
was looking at him in court I was 20
years old and I think I wasn't good to
see my 25th birthday and I was like yeah
whatever and I was doing the math it was
like 2008 I was like well in the world
gonna end in 2012 like that whole thing
right so it's like five years probation
code oh yeah I'm not gonna go experience
life and and yeah and I got out and I
mean that's pretty amazing
90 days yeah jail time yeah and then
everything else you can deal with you
know outside yeah and I just I didn't
know how because to that point like I
hadn't found a successful way to stop
doing drugs I think I was like how am I
gonna do this by knew like I knew I had
to because he was like if I completed
everything the felony come what come off
my record but I had no idea and then you
know I got out of court and I went to go
get high again and you know it was like
definitely like the one last hoorah went
to jail a week after my 21st birthday so
a few weeks later he gave me some time
though I kind of get my belonging he
spent some time with my family which I
didn't really do and I remember
reporting the jail or the report
reported to jail it was like I'm gonna
do as much oxy as I can I got a
prescription of suboxone to take in with
me because I was like all right well I'm
gonna detox in there
so I'm gonna need something like wean me
off and of course I didn't realize no
suboxone was a narcotic you bring that
they would and so I just I literally
like didn't like I think like two or
three 80 milligram pills before I went
in like and I literally did I must
impose on know of oxy and Roxy and then
having suboxone with me thinking I could
take it uh-huh and then I get there
they stripped me of all your belongings
and my life's confined no a small cell
with a bag and they're like you can't
take this a box I don't like why that's
prescribed to me they're like it's a
narcotic it's like oh no and then you
know day one it was just like it was
hell I mean I had no idea what was gonna
happen in there I was like you know
you're worried about all this stuff all
those stigmas of jail getting beat up
you know getting taken advantage of you
know and I just I didn't know what to
expect cuz I was I could have been a
model for Pillsbury at the time like I
was as heavy I was unathletic I couldn't
defend myself I wanted to and then I get
to jail and you know I ended up getting
kicked out of my first to cellmate cells
because I didn't read you know jail 101
on how to how to abide by the rules I
mean I ended up crawling into my first
cellmates bottom bunk when he was out
doing some stuff in the common area
because I was so weak I couldn't get up
to the top bunk cos and he comes in he's
like what are you doing then out I went
like [ __ ] I didn't get my butt kicked
and then my second one was this older
guy I ended up like doing something to
piss him off like using I was out of
toilet paper or something use his white
washcloths to like wipe my butt or
something I don't know that you needed
to read a manual on jail 101 to
understand that that was probably a bad
move I was like a please Ike beautiful
and they were like you were a zombie
when I first came in there and i detoxed
for like two or three weeks like hard
like I mean if you know vomiting feeling
like you're crawling out of your own
skin and and I saw this guy like he came
up to meet the Scrat was he was playing
Scrabble you think what are you doing in
here man maybe the pseudonym you might
my cellmate
and then that night after dinner I saw
him working out he was like you know
climbing the stairs and doing like
thousands of push-ups and I was like oh
my god like run in like McDavid Goggin
style you know what I mean like and and
I just who is this guy he said and he'd
been I've come to find out he had been
in for 10 years he was in the jail was
in honor on a detainer for violating a
probation and he just looked at me and
somehow he like he asked me a little bit
about me I shared a little bit my story
he was a you know opiate addict and he
he just kind of was like you're gonna
start working out with me and I was like
there's no way man there's no way I'm
gonna work out with you because the time
I'd never really done any organized
exercises in the gym class here and
there I mean my parents got me a trainer
but nothing like that like that lasted
it stuck it was almost like they knew I
needed to lose weight cuz I was always
the fat kid you know and I remember
finally after him being my cellmate
because he finally like it just happened
when I pissed off this old guy
his cellmate left and then he was a
guard you're in with me and he was like
once you get through your detox which
was even for about three weeks later
you're gonna start working out with me
and the first night man rich I tell you
it was humbling item I mean if I hadn't
been humbled enough but the stuff like
being able to not do a push-up from your
knees in front of a bunch of grown men
or hold yourself up in a plank and then
have your guy tell you it's because
you're fat is so humbling well I got a
whole bunch of questions for all could
you not have gotten high in jail I mean
there really was was there was there
wouldn't have been possible to score ah
there was some stuff that came in but
not really not liked it I mean not where
I will use red jail 101 maybe you would
have known how to you know ya know
people were brutal that for yourself
yeah I think so but I think people were
like I think people like the people were
coming in spend weekends and that's I
think when some of the stuff would come
in uh-huh but you know it wasn't like I
was in I wasn't in state prison where
it's not a prison it's different right
yeah I mean it's like not like it wasn't
there's not a lot of drug trade that go
in there because people are just I think
trying to get get in and get out of
there or trying to wait there cord and
not mess up hopefully before they go to
court all right and so the second thing
is then was there and was there like a
commitment to yourself like ok I'm gonna
I'm gonna get through this detox and I'm
gonna get sober or was it just like I
just I can't get anything in my system
today so I guess it is what it is like
was there a sense of like I got a like
sort this out for myself and get on a
new track it was more just a panic like
as I was going through it I didn't know
I didn't I didn't know I'd never gone
through this before so I had no idea
what to us was he never done a full
detox know what to expect and I was
shaking and I mean I don't know if I had
at that point I didn't really have a
desired but I'm never doing drugs again
I just was like I need to get through
this detox so I can like stop crying and
stop shaking and stop feeling so
nauseous all the time and he's in the
pain the aches came because you know I
baby was taking copious amounts of
painkillers that I'm like so like numb
yeah and then you know I had to wake up
once I got through that which was really
tough I had to realize that I had
nothing in my system anymore to numb the
pain so all the the stuff just came
before my my eyes as well have all the
stuff I had done all the stuff I'd never
really dealt with inside and it took a
lot because there was no drugs there was
no you know gambling or spending money
or whatever you know would fill the void
it was just me and I really had no
choice I mean then and then like you get
through detox and you realize well like
whoa like I'm in jail right now like you
know your mind starts to become less
foggy and they're like I gotta eat that
for lunch and it was like you know like
sweaty meat sandwiches we could call it
was like mystery Bologna me and Laura
like peanut butter jelly which wasn't I
would look for the peanut butter and
jelly dates the reality of your
situation kind of dawns on ya yeah and
and then when my cell mate was like
you're gonna start working out with me I
I just I was like what else do I have to
do in here we can only play spades
pinochle Scrabble and chess and tell war
stories for so long before I gotta do
something else right
so this guy Eric is right he becomes
your cellmate and this guy not only is
he
you know this fitness specimen like he
takes a real more than a real interest
in you like he basically becomes
obsessed with getting you fit like he
really takes you under his wing and like
this guy changes your life for better or
worse right so why what like what
motivated him to be so committed to you
I think you might have saw something
inside of me that just struck a nerve
with him I saw how much I was struggling
and for him he probably was in it he
knew he was in a spot where he had made
some poor decisions to get what to where
he was and to make himself feel better
you know cuz we all want to be of
service right it's like a natural thing
for us to want to help other people that
that was part of what he wanted was oh
I'm in he's like I'm you know I'm sure
he was like I'm in jail right now I got
nothing else to do why not this kid here
has poor goofy kid mm-hmm
it was a train wreck right now and kind
of like was like the Amy Dresner right
like how about I try and change his
kid's life and I don't know I don't know
why but I don't know why he picked me
out of all the P all the people but I
just thinks because I just as much as I
wanted to quit on him I never I never
quit and you know that why do you think
you never quit like what what got lit up
inside of you that made you suddenly go
from being you know just the Pillsbury
Doughboy that guy to being like I'm not
gonna let this guy down I'm gonna show
up I'm gonna do everything he says well
I think when I couldn't do a push-up
from my knees and I could barely walk up
and down the steps and like I was like
in the realization what my situation
actually was I said what have I come to
and then they also like a lot of the
people in my past I didn't believe in me
like they didn't believe me they're like
you're not gonna make it like you're
going to rehab when you get out and
thought of it like all the negative
stuff that I had no one no one like
believed I was gonna really make it and
I just wanted to prove people wrong and
then once I was able to see some
progress
like I think I was able to do like I
said a few push-ups from my knees I was
like wow there's magic in this and then
once I and then Eric for some reason I
believe everything he said for
everything and I think I could just feel
in my heart that it was like authentic
and genuine from a place where he was
coming back he had nothing to lose right
and and then it just it really started
where we set the goal to do 10 push-ups
when I left and then to run a mile and I
felt like this light switch starts to go
off in my head like the same monkey that
I felt come off my back when I was
smoking pot was the same monkey come off
my back when I was running and I would
run and even and sometimes like I mean
it's a start I could obviously only run
like 1/10 of a mile we'd have like this
common area inside jail where all the
tables were set out at and there'd be
TVs and there'll be people playing
Scrabble and games and stuff and you
could run around the perimeter so I
would hold like a call I got deck of
cards and I would count you know 1 2
like the laps and so one of the oh how
big was this room it wasn't big I don't
remember how many laughs as a mile must
have been like I don't know it was a lot
like so there's no gym no no gym you
just you're doing push-ups on the floor
in the common room and yeah on the
concrete it's like you know and and so I
just felt like I felt like I could be
able to to kind of relieve the stress of
whatever had going on my life by running
by doing push-ups by seeing by by
starting to achieve some goals like I
was able do a few pushes my knees that
led to me doing a push-up for my feet
and then I was like I was starting to
see some differences in my body because
he put me on like a jailhouse food plan
where I couldn't eat the bread and I
couldn't eat like the Snickers bars and
you know we did have cheap meals on
Sunday we would call Mike hook ups where
we would take all our like you take Rob
we get ramen noodles off commissary
cheesy rice like the little dude like
little sausages and the meat from the
week and we'd put it all on a plastic
trash bag and use boiling water tie it
off and then like let it sit like with
like 30 minutes you know like
Thanksgiving in the joint super gourmet
my guys you want to hook up and they're
like what you want to like make you a
hookup
they were like and I was telling like
dude that sounds absolutely disgusting
huh but so and but so then might all the
people inside of the jail like besides
my cellmate were like cheering me on
because they saw when I came in I was a
zombie
let's get kicked out of cells I was like
you know freaking out asking a million
questions about what jail was gonna be
like and then like the consistency they
saw the consistency of me running and
when I was able to to do the push-ups I
remember my dad and my brothers coming
in to visit me and this was like the
turning point for me and you know he was
you know we want he wanted me that he
was very Stern about me going to rehab
and this and that and I just didn't I
was like listen I was like screw rehab I
found fitness and and whether I believed
it or not I had to believe in myself
because if I didn't believe in it at all
I wouldn't have been I won't be what
wouldn't have gotten started to where be
where I am today and he started yelling
at me I'm just hanging up that was how
much worse could it be I'm in jail right
now and I hung up the phone walked out
and walked into mice to my cellmate I
was like let's [ __ ] work out and he
was like what the heck just happened to
you I was like any and I just told him
how my dad and I got no fight he was
like you know what that inspire you and
that's what like kept me going was like
all the people that the things that
doubted me all the stuff that I never
was able to accomplish like fueled my my
inspiration to change really did yeah
your story is similar to other people
I've had on the show who've been in you
know comparable predicaments from John
McAvoy Chris Schumacher was in on a
murder charge
Charlie Engle who would just run around
the you know basically running ultra
marathons and and my sense is that when
you're in an environment where you're
stripped of you know your freedom and on
some level your dignity there's so
little that you have control over right
and and how you move your body
throughout the day is something that you
do have control over and it's a way of
maintaining that sense of self and and
saying you know you could take this from
me but you can't take that yeah I mean I
had nothing else nothing else to do and
that was that one of the hardest part to
be honest was leaving I cried when I
left so I had no idea what was gonna
happen and my when I was well you had a
commute
it sounds like I mean not only did you
have this guy Eric you had all these
people cheering for you
and you know if you ask somebody like
gab or Ma Tei or Johann Hari about the
root roots of addiction you know Johann
famously always says like the opposite
of addiction isn't isn't sobriety it's
connection right and you develop this
connection with these people in it in a
way that's healthier from your boys that
you're driving around in stone with oh
yeah and suddenly you're gonna be
extracted from that environment like of
course I would you know I I would
suspect that that was terrifying for
somebody who's newly sober who really
doesn't know what to expect when they go
back out into the world yeah I mean I
just
that was one my biggest fears like what
am I gonna do now without these people
what am I gonna do and I remember there
was one night I cheated on my diet and
my cellmate he was always like if you
cheat on your diet I'm punching you in
the stomach and I knew it was really
doughy and if he punched me in the
stomach I might end up in like the jail
er and so I never cheat but there was
one night I just and somebody told on me
a number I hated it but I needed it he
was a guard Doug you know the deal
you're they're gonna run like two miles
or I'm punching you some other dude
there's a prison rap okay with you
snitched on me he's like dude she's
doing it for help just trying to help
you out and I remember writing my mom
this letter when I was in jail and it
was funny I I just was going through she
the reason I say this is kind of bring
some things into perspective is you know
my mom and I I was the one that I always
had just I wish I hadn't done some of
the things that I did because I I drill
I know I really hurt her and she was
always kind of she was emotionally kind
of timid from the divorce and obviously
the MS and everything and I was going
through a file with her probably must
have been six months maybe I mean not
even six months ago maybe three or four
months ago and she's a goodness in my
house and it's a Doug jail is like a
manila folder with like my my court
documents in it and it was some letters
I had written her in the one letter
which I completely forgot that I wrote
her I was just talking about how much
changing while I'm in there and that I
don't I just want her to be happy when I
talked her on the phone and that I'm not
gonna let her down I like stuff I mean I
don't know exactly what it said it was
something to that nature and then I look
back at it now and I'm like holy crap
like it really happened and I remember
writing those letters and not even
really thinking that things were gonna
change I had no idea because I knew that
I got it I had to get out and I had to
deal with stuff of my own then I had all
this probation and I had to battle for
the next five years of not failing a
drug test because the judge was like you
know if he said to me he said if I see
you in my courtroom again you're gonna
be sharing a cell with Bubba and I
didn't I knew I wouldn't last long
I was not Eric no and and so when that
but a couple days before I got out you
know there was a lot of emotions between
me and me and Eric I was like what am I
gonna do without you you think he'll be
fine he's like I said how can I ever pay
you back right and he said just keep
paying it forward keep helping other
people and keep doing you I keep and
give me a foundation he gave me a
workout plan that I still have framed in
my place today so I never forget where I
came from that has like our some of the
original stuff he told me to do whether
it was like five or six sets of push-ups
one day and the next day I was running
three to five miles and but he had some
some words on there he said remember
you're no longer a fat ass again ever
have to be one again like eat smart I
guess I'm not there it's up to you and
because he's still in jail I don't know
where he's at now I mean him and I we
did we eat steak we actually worked out
together a few times when he got out but
I don't know what I know he was kind of
still in and out of some stuff I don't
know where he was but I got dedicated my
first book to him if he ever called me I
would pick up the phone and I remember
writing him a letter when I first got
out and I love with my grandparents and
it was so cold it was like you know in
January and I wrote him away I was like
it's cold out I can't run outside he's
like I train machines not [ __ ] he said
that's mean a letter or something like
that I like that he still thinks he's
your trainer it was like you better go
buy spare sweatpants and you know that
that kind of those kind of words don't
speak to everybody and I get that but to
me it did like it just it was just what
needed to hear and the him being hard on
me and for some reason being honest like
yeah you're a fat ass
yeah the fat what do you want you know
what do you want to what do you want
from me he's like and I mean I was
wondering what like why can't I do it
why can't he's like you're fat like you
have a load of fat you have no core
strength he's like and and like a lot of
lessons he taught me and a lot of what
about not giving up for myself and
helping other people and unconditional
love or things I still carry on with me
today that have kind of really
influenced my recovery and my
relationships with other people
uh-huh so you get released you're a
felon right you're young you're a young
guy yeah your whole life ahead yeah like
you know what it's gotta be disorienting
and confusing like how am I gonna what
am I gonna do now yeah I mean I I had I
still had a lot of my same friends and
not they were bad people but they I just
couldn't I couldn't drive with that
lifestyle anymore yeah and so I live
with my grandparents and they gave me
the rules of you know you're gonna stay
here you can stay here rent-free we'll
buy either buy your food we'll give you
money to go you know do whatever as long
as we have receipts for what you're
doing and then you got a you know clean
up after yourself have a job but it's
like the minute you don't follow those
rules are out which is what I needed and
so I kept obviously after my cellmates
first letter I began to run I got myself
some sweatpants I would work out in
their basement doing push-ups and
jumping jacks and whatever else was part
of the routine he gave me and then when
I bothe enough confidence in myself I
joined like a local Planet Fitness but I
had to look for a job cuz I had like 20
jobs about time I went to jail like I
mean I worked in restaurants torn pizza
I'm gonna had quite the resume of
somebody who don't want to hire because
I lasted like a few months at each job
or I beg like I can make $7 an hour go
sell drugs and ironically after banging
on the doors for months checking the box
and I'm a convicted felon I got hired at
a liquor store so to me I was like well
I mean this is either gonna make me want
to like drink like crazy or it's gonna
make me not want to drink hardly at all
and it really like influenced that
showed me like obviously the other
lifestyle that I had never really seen
I've never really seen people like
banging on the
doors before our liquor store open to
get alcohol I'd never seen that because
alcohol was never my thing it was just I
was I didn't even like the taste of it
really I mean I couldn't even drink beer
it was kind of gross and and so I worked
there and while most would say it's a
horrible decision I mean I somehow they
gave me a chance I was open with him
about my felony I was able to I showed
up to work every day I just took that as
that opportunity of gratitude for
somebody give me a chance I continued to
I made time to work out whether was
before I went to work after I went to
work so I was working 40 hours a week
and I just built some great
relationships with the people I worked
with and ended up blessed and about it
was boobs weird rich like my whole like
outlook on work change like every time I
was going to work before I went to jail
it was like I can't wait to leave like I
cannot wait to leave or I don't want to
be here anymore but here I was like I
just had this different mentality of
like alright I'm hearing to work I got
to do my job and then when I'm done I
can leave and I just I don't know I
don't know what changed but I guess it
was the combination of me feeling better
about myself and also the fact that I
had a new lifestyle that I thought was I
was embracing and you know within a few
months after getting released after I
got the job
like Saturday nights became watching
Food Network for my grandparents right
there's that thing when you're in the
throes of addiction you know I went
through a lot of this where it's like
you just you feel trapped like if you're
in a job you're you're like a caged
animal and I just can't wait to leave
because when you leave then you can go
use right and then when you're sober
that gets taken away and you have this
mindset shift of that goes from like
what what can i you know what's the
maximum that I can extract out of this
experience for myself in a very selfish
way to what can I contribute right you
know and the more you get into that kind
of service-oriented contribution mindset
then shockingly the more gratifying the
experience is and the less you feel like
a caged animal who wants to leave yeah I
completely agree it was more like yeah
you said like how much am I getting paid
for this job like when can I come when
can I leave how can I try and score
drugs on my lunch break I mean I was
working at a car wash I then people
stopped through to buy drugs for me
while I was working - now you know being
that's some hustle that's uh some dumb
hustle because this guy could buy my
boss and I came up to me he's like man
you realize this guy accused me of like
is taking a pound of weed out of his car
he's like a pound you know how much that
is and I'm like yeah I'm like thinking
myself I have one in my trunk right now
but he's still working at the liquor
store I was able to to just you know
people were starting to notice like to
react respond to me differently they're
like wow you're so passionate you're so
happy and it was just complete shift in
mindset and I guess the help of me
exercising just made it all better
yeah so why did you not go to try to
find community in naa earn 12 stuff um I
mean I did go to one NA meeting when I
was in jail but just to slowly get out
of my jail cell wasn't like I wanted to
do anything with it I just I don't know
I I didn't really I didn't know anybody
who went to AAA so it wasn't like I
didn't I didn't really know anybody so I
just I kind of just thought okay I'm
gonna work out I'm gonna run I'm gonna
eat better and if I can lose weight and
feel better about myself that'll make me
not want to like mask my insecurities
with drugs anymore and if I can just
follow the rules of like what my
grandparents said and the job I
currently had in probation but I
wouldn't mess up any more so it wasn't
that I didn't want I just never it was
never really in front of me like yeah I
went to the there was a mandatory
outpatient classes I went to for like I
don't know I was like eight weeks once a
week or something ready to pee in a cup
those are super depressing though oh my
gosh
so I mean there was that well that's the
weird thing with with na and na and
twelve stuff that you know the unanimity
is is part of the whole deal right so
with that I mean there's there's
benefits and advantages to that because
if you're in there you have you know you
can remain anonymous but at the same
time it prevents the program from being
known to somebody like yourself right
who's like well I don't know anyone
there and I don't even know where it is
and you know and then you just left your
own imagination about how horrible it
probably is and then you never go yeah I
mean I didn't really have anybody I knew
well I knew saw a few people that had
tried to get
sober and whatnot but like I really
didn't know and I didn't know anybody
like I really I didn't know I and so I
just kind of kept on the path of running
and and then working out which work I
mean I would my personality changed my
outlook on life change my passion for
when help other people was like greater
than ever and then it like obviously it
led me to wanting to be to become a
trainer about a year and a half later to
help other people you know use Fitness
to change their lives in the way that
changed mine so it's been a little over
a year ten or eleven years at this point
yeah I mean I I went to jail
Sep know October 21st 2008 I got
released December 26 2008 yeah so I mean
it's been almost I mean over ten years I
mean I've had once at you Oh on the day
after my birthday
yeah that's right cuz you're a Libra too
right or twenty oh yeah my birthday is
the 13th oh it is yeah so a week first
birthday it's supposed to be like
celebratory and never haven't had a
relapse no I mean I've had some like
drinks here in the egg here and like a
glass of wine here glass something
because you know to me like and again I
didn't get involved in that 12-step
community I know in the 12-step
community it's you know app complete
apps total abstinence so I I my
understanding was as long as I'm not
doing the drugs I was abusing like
opiates and coke and pot that I was good
and I never had a fake honestly I could
have a glass of wine I I might not drink
for two year I mean there's been times
I've been drinking for years and I just
can take it or leave it and you know I
had a friend tell me who's in recovery
say sometimes kids when they get sober
at a young age they're able later in
life to experience its alcohol in some
cases you know drink here or there and
again I don't I mean I don't know if
that's dangerous for me ya know there's
a joke that I have with some of my
friends some of which like I've got I
have friends that are like thirty five
years sober you know they're like my age
or in their forties you know they got
sober super young it's like and I and I
always joke with them I you could
probably drink now
it'll be fine you know and they they
laugh because they know like in their
heart of hearts they know like they
can't do that if they do it it's like
game you know like anything can happen
yeah
certain people are wired that way I mean
alcohol wasn't your drug of choice it
wasn't the entry for you to other things
and you know I can't speak for anybody
other than my own experience I know for
myself like I can't that option is off
the table for me but god bless you man
well and I think it's like I look at why
if I'm like if I come home and I'm like
stress and I'm started drinking like
I've never really gotten to that it's
more like if I'm out like on a date or
if I'm out like social like something
like social which I mean but and I
honestly don't do it that I mean I could
probably count the amount of drinks I've
had on my one hand in the last few years
I mean it's just
mm-hmm but I mean well I'm very open
about it and less like you know I was
you know I'm when I used to one of my
clients was a treatment center and I
would train the patients there was a
12-step program and you know I would
never be open about that with them
unless I mean if they asked I wouldn't
lie but I didn't want people getting the
idea that they can do that - because my
walk is my walk I mean I just have built
in different ways to manage my stress
today than I did back then and you know
if it ever became an issue then I would
have to look at what I'm doing but right
now it's you know it works the time
being so what are the ways in which you
manage your stress outside of just
working out well I mean I think you know
spirituality has been big for me I mean
I mean I'm a Christian I like jam it
down people's throats because I didn't
like it being jammed down my throat and
you know I didn't always believe in God
because I was like if God's real and
God's about love why am i incarcerated
why am i addicted to drugs why this why
that why me why me me me and I didn't
believe any and then but then I hit that
point you know several years into my
recovery where I thought just working
out making good money would make be
sustainably happy and you should surely
get humbled it like huh and then my one
of my mentors Todd Durkin who's a
trainer in San Diego was like Doug you
need like some spiritual outing like
whatever it whatever works for you right
and and so one of my clients was a was a
pastor and he's like you know you're
gonna start coming to church with me
it's a non denominator it's like dude I
on the highway to hell I'm going through
hell for putting you through this
workout
and there's no way and you know finally
I hit that point where I needed that
thing i calling and i went and called my
client I was like I need to like come to
church and and I was almost 5 years ago
and what was that moment like why then
like what was going I mean I just had
gotten you know nothing was working in
my personal life was like working
working as far as like relate like like
female relationships and I was having a
lot of doubts about myself a lot of like
you know resentments towards like the
choices I had made and being a former
convicted felon and all this stuff that
I just couldn't deal with and I and then
also like the part of me was like kept
looking back and being like man like
this guy had this crazy story that
people tell me like I couldn't have done
it myself like and so everything I was I
came back from the Disney World from a
business retreat and I remember just
crying at the retreat because I was at a
business like a fitness retreat we focus
on like personal business development
and I couldn't like wrap my head around
why I was like super fit making good
money and why I still wasn't completely
happy and then the spirituality nudge
kept coming from some of my peers and
again and I just thought I should just I
got nothing to lose I'll try it and like
this ain't like this cific when I went
to the church for the first time I'm
like pray with my client the same feel I
say monkey they came off my back with
the pot the opiates and then like the
the fitness part came off my back in a
deeper level like that I can't even
explain I got called my mom like for the
first time like ever like an
authentically apologize to her when I
walked out of there and I felt like
there was something there was a bigger
reason for me to be alive and at this
point I'm a trainer so I'm like you
can't make up that Fitness save my leg I
used Fitness to help save my life in
jail and now I'm helping other people
use Fitness to save their lives you
can't just I can't do that myself and
I've slowly began to think like I might
not be happy with the choices that I
made but God was and for me it works and
it just it really helped me and then you
know if you want to dive into that a
little bit more we can but I think also
having mentors in my life people that
have walked the walk a bit deeper I
started getting involved in like
mastermind
in personal development stuff and I was
like 22 years old so who were your guys
in that regard I mean like Todd Dirk and
the guy in San Diego and I started
following like Gary Vee so I actually
got to meet Gary for the first time like
a few few weeks ago I was up at
vaynermedia and I were cool yeah for an
interview of one of his podcasts not his
but um his new lifestyle grin 137 PMO
137 and um I was like I was like I was
like wondering I was like asking the guy
who was dinner so I guess Gary Harris I
was love like I love Gary I was like I
just I just love anything I don't know
he's always running around I literally
like going the bathroom washing my hands
and you know Gary's got that distinct
voice and like Gary Vee I know I got
like shake his head where they were in
the bathroom and he's like I can we
please get a picture together and I was
like and then you start talking to me
and and it was really cool like that guy
like him who I know obviously I'm sure
gets bothered by him tons of people was
super authentic when I saw him like in
his his realm he's the he's exactly who
you want him to be when the camera's not
on like my experience with him is super
positive and every time I bumped into
him or seeing him he could not be nicer
or more kind or more generous like
everything that he preaches he practices
in his own life yeah and it was really
cool to see that you know with him
because you get sometimes you meet these
guys some of these guys and they're like
totally different internally toe turns
you off and then obviously following
like guys like Tony Robbins and if any
other trying to think of who else I mean
when I really first got into recovery I
started reading like fitness magazines
too which which helped me like figure
out how to eat and I mean I even though
now look back I can't believe I read
some of this stuff like Muscle & Fitness
or Arnold Schwarzenegger is like book a
bodybuilder he was like the first book I
read and but I just I did also my client
a lot of my clients were either like
lawyers and they were like CPAs or
financial planners they were all like
pretty successful so I was always like
picking their brain and be like well how
did you do it and I was always like a
listen and absorb information and and I
just always knew that I never had the
answer and if I was the smartest person
in the room I needed get into different
rooms and so just I just I don't know I
got really I guess lucky in the sense
that I just jumped on these
opportunities to
meet people in a network and just be
like hey how can I help you what can I
do for you like what can i I mean and
just see where stuff leads well it
sounds like you had a willingness to
grow and learn and to expand and you
sought out these people whether
virtually or in person for guidance and
counsel that you clearly you know lacked
in your own life and at the same time
you invested in you know a spiritual
program for yourself and I would imagine
you you probably look back on that jail
experience now and and everything that
you endure to get to where you are at
this point with a level of gratitude
that that you didn't expect to have
right well yeah I mean if you would ask
me now if I would have cried when I left
jail there was like cried like yeah like
maybe in joy but I was crowd cried of
like I was nervous because I didn't want
to leave and it was I needed that
experience I needed that and I don't
know you know I don't know where my
spiritual awakening actually was I mean
I know I've had probably had several in
my life but being in jail was definitely
the big one because I just all the masks
I've been putting on myself came off at
once and it was like okay Doug here you
are you're a fat ass you've gotten
yourself in jail you can't do what you
want see what you want you know go where
you want or talk to who you want like
what are you gonna do about it what was
your greatest aspiration for your life
when you were driving around you know
scammin french fries and delivering
pizzas and it's getting stoned I mean I
really wanted to be like either in the
like I wanted to be there be in the FBI
or be like a sports broadcaster for ESPN
and and that was but those are two of my
things and you know I went from also I
wanted to obviously be a lawyer an
accountant but and I mean I narrowed it
down I wanted to be in the FBI and or be
on ESPN and obviously when I got
arrested I was well there goes the FBI
no FBI it was gonna be some kind of
informant it's funny though cuz cuz you
know 10 years might seem like a long
time but it's
not that long and and and when I think
of you kind of driving around with one
headlight you know just a disaster -
like being on The Today Show and like
going to vaynermedia like you've got a
lot of press for the stuff that you've
done like you're kind of a name who's
out there who's learned how to own your
story and tell it in a certain way and
and and you know clearly for the sake of
inspiring other people and motivating
other people to take better control of
their lives I mean you know in a certain
respect you you're you're becoming that
like beat that lighthouse and that
beacon of light for people that you
sought out in your own time of need yeah
I mean I'm just gonna I'm just trying to
help people I mean I don't have any like
other mission behind behind it and it's
like I just I just really want to use my
story just I mean I'm there's bit
there's bits and pieces that can relate
whether it's how you struggle with
mental illness and how you cope with
that or whether it's you know a mom
listening who's got a kid right now who
just started smoking pot and like oh
what do I do
cuz you know my kids tell me pots legal
here and you know I see him like not
doing his homework for three weeks in a
row or if it's just somebody who like
doesn't think they can ever get started
and taking care of their body like I was
that person like I was the guy you know
I mean it wasn't yo-yo dieting but I
would like eat like once a day and it
would be like a whole cheese steak pizza
and fries and I thought that was like
cool like that was like delicious and
then like as I look back now and as I've
experienced with almost every you know
diet I mean I hate I don't really like
that word but lifestyle you can just I'm
like wow well it's just funny how
cheesesteaks and pizza aren't part of
any of these other you know equations
when it comes to how to eat yeah what's
interesting about your story is is it
it's like the intersection of so many
things that are like gone off the rails
in our society from our obsession with
success and comfort and luxury like oh
I'm you know a good life is a life of
you know getting a good paycheck and
having a nice car and having a job that
people approve of
you kind of playing that out in some
level and seeing like I'm not I'm not
happy with that
to this you know mental health crisis
that we find ourselves in where more
people are depressed or suffering some
from some form of anxiety or you know
suicidal ideation or PTSD or
what-have-you I mean it's flagrant and
everywhere we look to the opioid crisis
to you know all of these problems that
were kind of suffering from culturally
you're like this you know test-tube case
study you know who kind of came out the
other side but can speak to all of these
issues as somebody who's endured them
yeah I mean and it's it's been tough I
mean to say that it's been an easy road
what I mean the amount of energy it's
probably taken just to kind of maintain
all this it's been hard it's hard
because you know I'm so used to you know
having to always watch my back I could
be being on like probation for five
years I mean it was definitely tough and
not not me not failing drug tests and
having the felon come off my record was
was great but having that like on your
shoulders like it correlates and no like
haven't you haven't you for you to have
you to watch your back in other areas of
your life and but if I can just be a
beacon or an inspiration of hope to
people either hear my story and know
that like I'm just here to just
scriptures here to help people it's not
like I'm trying to sell any programs I
mean I'm just I'm honestly like float
like floating my own the paying for all
the stuff to myself to travel just to
help other people like that's what it's
about for me I mean it's just about if I
can did the emails I get or the texts I
get from people who see this or listen
to that and I go my gosh like I needed
this right now I needed to hear your
story and I mean to me that's what
life's about paying it forward what do
you think is the difference between your
experience and the experience of the
untold thousands of other oxy addicts
out there who get pulled over and
arrested and go to jail and never change
their ways like why were you able to you
know grab onto this lifeline and and
make these changes to become this person
who's like writing book
doing podcast you know like it's it's an
amazing trajectory yeah I mean other
than right place right time I mean and I
said as I look back in one of my biggest
motivators for believing in God wasn't
like seeing this this person right it
was just looking at where wild life was
to where it is now and being like I
can't do that myself and if I could the
moment I continued to remember I'd to
try to say that I did this myself is the
moment I lose because then my ego ego is
the enemy right he goes one and and I
think it also came back to taking
responsibility I mean like I said my
cellmate being really point blank to me
like doesn't resonate in the way it does
for might not resonate and with with
many but he said to me he's like even be
a man or you can be a [ __ ]
three said to me when I got in when I
got in there and he's like you can be a
man and take responsibility for yourself
know that you got yourself here no
matter who you want to blame no matter
who did this you got yourself here and
it's up to you to change or you can be a
[ __ ] no crying the corner Salkin your
sorrows and blame everybody else like
most people will do and I just kind of
took that and I don't want to say ran
with it but I just kind of did it and I
was just on such a mission to to never
you know give up and to know that life
was gonna be better for me if I did
these things and if I didn't do these
things I was gonna fail
I had no shot at all but I knew if I did
these things I had a shot and slowly you
know it was like things started to fall
into place and I mean I think I just I
got lucky in a way but I think I was
just so determined rich to change I
really was well divine providence place
this guy Eric in your path you know and
and I would imagine you look at that
with a sense of not just gratitude but
but in a way that instills your life
with faith because you couldn't have
predicted that that changes the course I
mean had that guy not been there and it
just been a bunch of dudes who like I
can care less about you like where would
your life be right now I mean you
couldn't even imagine right I mean I
wouldn't been working out for sure yeah
so you know what is that if not you know
I would choose I guess I could say I
choose to look at that
as you know an act of an act of God you
know you it doesn't have to be the word
God can be replaced for whatever
spiritual turn of phrase yeah feels
comfortable for you but there's so much
beauty and poetry and elegance in that
yeah I mean I think it's just no matter
what spirituality believing if you
believe in it or not to me it was just
his willingness to help me with no
strings attached
unconditional love right and and then
paying it forward and then just it was
he was like an angel to me at that time
when I needed him and him not letting me
give up cuz he could have easily been
like dude you're a pain in my ass
you [ __ ] way too much you whine I get
away from me like why why am I gonna
waste my time but he didn't get it and
let me quit and even when I got out of
jail I mean he didn't have to write me
back but he did and you know he once I
was trying to bail out in a way he was
like what the heck did I teach you when
you were incarcerated like go get
yourself a pair of sweatpants and stop
being a wuss and and so like though that
they kind of like just that
unconditional love I didn't want to let
that guy down because I was like I just
I don't know why but I was like if I let
this guy down like my life's over
because like I have this golden
opportunity and when the fella when he
came off I just you know everyone was
like I remember people in court crying
and I'm just standing there I didn't
really understand what it really
happened I mean it just so it was so you
Fork but I mean it was cool to be able
to go back to court to see the judge and
him look at me in a positive way and see
the judicial system which many of us
have come to to hate when it comes to
the way people treat drug offenders to
actually do some good for once yeah this
is something that that John McAvoy talks
about a lot the power of the redemptive
power of sport and he's essentially
devoted a huge part of his life to
trying to reform the prison system to
instill it with sports related
activities and programs to rehabilitate
the population and your you know a
similar example
of that rehabilitative power of taking
control of your your fitness yeah I mean
it's it's just so important for the mind
I mean just to feel better about
yourself and having that dedication of
no one okay I got to do this activity at
7:00 a.m. whether it's working out or
going outside and playing basketball and
then like the you know the endorphin
rush that you get and just being able to
like get uncomfortable or get
comfortable being uncomfortable recovery
it's uncomfortable a lot of times right
you lose a job you get a divorce you get
somebody who chastises you on social
media whatever it is that makes you
uncomfortable you got to deal with it in
a healthy and a healthy way right first
part of getting sober is the experience
of being about as uncomfortable as you
can possibly be right weathering a detox
and what you learn from that is that you
can't short-circuit it like I'm sure if
you they'd allowed you to get the
suboxone in there a little bit easier
but if it was too easy maybe you would
have gone back you know what I mean
there's there's there's there's there's
beauty in that suffering because with
that comes the lesson and if you short
if you try to short-circuit that you're
missing out on what is trying to be
taught to you right and I think when you
can appreciate the difficulty of
weathering and experience like that it
allows you to see that those experiences
are necessary in order to grow and
ultimately they they provide the
foundation for you to be a happier more
purposeful person yeah I mean that's
exactly kind of what it did for me is
like getting in the recovery starting
the workout got me uncomfortable but it
also led me into meeting other people
along the way and then meeting people
that challenged me to write books I mean
I didn't want to write my first book but
you know people were like you got this
crazy story why don't you write a book
and I was like I barely graduated high
school like what do I know about writing
and then like you know then I went to
write it and then I wrote it and then
people were like oh this is pretty good
and I'm like oh is it like and and then
so then that led me know to meet some
other people and in Channel
myself more than be inspired to like you
know write this next book where the my
newest book that comes out in March to
to really help other people and I've
just met some so many cool people and
just following people like you know
along the way that just inspire the heck
out of me with their recovery and you
know reading your book was awesome and
just I was there was a lot of things I
related to there with you know the what
happened you in school and then you know
obviously with getting sober and then
with the role Fitness play in your life
and the be honest was fine I deliver
pizza to well you know it's funny is you
were doing that I was reading about you
doing the epic five and that point where
you like blacked out you didn't remember
you know and he didn't know if you're
gonna go on and then like Jason was like
come on we're running this marathon I
was hiking up I've never really hiked a
mountain before on the other day I was
in Arizona with my buddy it was a
Thursday or from a Friday we were hiking
and I was like I was smoked and then I
just in my mind I was just like thinking
about you and the epic five my dude I'm
a complete wuss right now compared
awesome so tell me about the new book
the heart of recovery so this comes out
of March and these are like sort of key
studies of interviewing a bunch of
people who've turned their lives around
in in sobriety yeah so I mean I being
somebody who's been in recovery for you
know a little over a decade I just
gotten to the point where I was like
people were like how would you get sober
without going AAA and I was like well I
did this this and that and you know I
just I was you know I knew that I had a
problem with the drugs I was abusing I
couldn't do it I knew I had I believe in
God and I had made him like amends for
them like that I mean I don't have any
anger towards like my family but I'd you
know it communicated with them and and I
have you know people I call when I'm in
trouble like sponsors if you will and
and so I just knew I was doing very
similar things and I just saw the
epidemic obviously not getting any
better and realizing that people getting
into recovery they're not healthy like
there's people they're still smoking
tons of cigarettes or eating unhealthy
and I'm like who how can I correlate a
message to help people
get better so I decided that I wanted to
write like an interview style book where
I interviewed like you know 50 the most
of some of the most inspiring people
that are recovery about how they did it
like what their workout routines were
like what kind of people that hung out
with there's what their view on
spirituality was and almost like you
know what they do on a day-to-day basis
to to thrive in recovery and I wanted a
vast diverse group of people from people
who were celebrities the people who are
new people just to show that whether you
were 50 million or 50 dollars like
recovery and addiction doesn't
discriminate you still gotta work a
program but just work what works for you
and while there's a lot of people in
there that are 12-step people and it's
definitely worked for them there's
people in there that aren't and it's
worked for them and you know I just
think we kind of need to stop putting
that thing and it's like a
one-size-fits-all approach because you
know think if it was I think we wouldn't
be where we're at today I mean there's
so many other issues that go into it
yeah well I mean we're you know the the
fact that the two of us are sitting here
you know who both have leverage fitness
for personal growth and in our own
unique ways we we've also had different
paths and sobriety you know and like I
have no judgment on how you got sober
and stay sober my past a little bit
different but I think it does speak to
the fact that like yeah I mean I know it
works for me but that doesn't mean it's
a one-size-fits-all thing and I
appreciate the fact that you would like
you know kind of create a catalogue of
all these different perspectives for for
you know somebody to be able to turn to
and and find you know of all of these
here's the one that I can identify with
so maybe I'll model my path after this
person yeah and there's different
stories in there there's some names
people recognize some don't but I think
it's like I really wanted to include a
lot of names that people don't recognize
because those are the names that don't
like it talked about and you know just
different people's perspectives on their
workout routines to their views on
spiritual they're all different and all
those personalities are different just
so people can pick and choose what they
want to nibble on and like you know
that's its its laid out so people can
just read this story at a time there's a
table of contents that helps people kind
of journal through I mean there's some
there's some really funny stories in
there and there's some you read some
about some people that you're like man
how the heck did they get through it and
I met some amazing people along along
the way and you know just connected with
some some really cool people that I
still have relationships with now just
because I was like it was weird like
reaching out to the publicist and man I
had no experience of doing it all none
there like who are you and I'm like I'm
Doug bobe's I'm a trainer in Maryland
they're like why are you calling yeah
you know and I'm like oh my god right in
the book and they're like well who's
your publisher and I'm like uh I'm you
know I just wanted to write the book and
I was just like I just had this
seriously hustle like crazy because I to
get this done because I nobody knew me I
know and I didn't have like a nice em
self-publishing I don't have a big
publisher but I just knew that I wanted
to write the book and I wanted to help
people and I think there's a lot of
people that just respected that I was
nobody and like wow you're doing this on
like your own time I'm not affiliated
with it working for a treatment center I
don't you know I I just this is just me
paging through the book yeah I there's a
lot of people in here though right now
not everyone I mean some of these names
I don't know but there's like some of it
is like oh this is a little bit of a
who's who of LA I was like Amy must have
turned you on to that person well I mean
there were certain people I just they
were like how can I help you I was like
and I would be honest I'd be like I mean
if you don't like if you know anybody
would be open right they would do it
it's not gonna like ask me a million
questions it's like gonna you know
that's gonna be open to the eleventh
tradition which I know is big in LA I
said just your army to him and I was
thankful that a lot of people helped me
out and I also just was persistent like
because I knew I had knew people were
busy and once I got somebody on the
phone it was a little easier because I
could hear my voice I would share my
story and it wasn't like I was just that
other person like reaching out to him
for something it was like okay like it
seems legitimate what you want to do
because you know at first I wanted to
get as many celebrities as I could then
I realize like hey it's really really
hard me being nobody and be like I
wanted to get like a lot of stories in
there too that nobody knows because
those are the stories that people can
row like everyday people can they're not
gonna be able to relate to people who
can afford to put themselves to rehab a
bunch or or I mean they can in some ways
but you know it's the everyday person
that's working like a two jobs
you know can't get through it what did
you learn from this experience what
what's surprising what surprised you I
mean I just think that you know rich
there's a lot of different themes and
there's a lot of different paths but
there's a lot of commonalities too I
mean the people in there for the most
part I mean I would say I mean I would
like probably I'd say all they all like
you know the relationships change for
the better when they got into recovery
they hang out with people that bring the
best out in them they have a workout
routine that that works that works for
them or if they're not currently working
out because of injury or something they
know the importance of it they value it
and they and they all I kind of know
what they need to do every day to to
kind of stay on top of things and and
they were all like really an interesting
to talk to like it was all like there
were so many people just willing to do
it cuz they wanted to be part of it but
you know and I also learned like how
there's a lot of politics I guess in
recovery too and there's a lot of
gatekeepers and certain things I mean I
wasn't aware of because I'm in the
fitness industry so that kind of was
eye-opening to me and I didn't I didn't
know and it was it was hard to fight
through but I guess I realized it's just
what it is so I mean that was a big
learning experience was like just
because you're calling a manager a
publicist if somebody doesn't means
they're gonna give you an interview
right it's really hard you know and a
lot of people want these interviews and
I just like I didn't know because I'd
never been through this process before
all I knew was fitness I mean I didn't
know I mean but by the grace of God I
was able to get some of the interviews I
got in there just by yeah help of other
people and you know some I got on my own
through publicist but I missed off well
one thing I'm pretty sure nobody said to
you is this when I got sober I thought
that my life would be over and that it
would just be boring from then on out
and they were right it was boring right
it's like no your life gets better it
does you think that you're gonna be
resigned to this milquetoast existence
and and you know there'll be no more
high highs and low lows and you know on
some level yes of course your evening
things out but on the whole like I have
been privy to witnessing live so Germany
radically changed as a result of getting
sober that it's it's it's almost beyond
what is believable yeah I mean it lives
definitely changed for the better and
for people I mean there's a lot of
people like we were saying you know
earlier that they're like I don't my
life's not gonna be any better but it
does get better I mean you are able to
hold a job your relationships to improve
the way you feel about yourself is
better because you don't have that like
weight weighing you down anymore and and
I think you know you are able to do some
work on yourself by getting into
recovery is like a huge step in working
on yourself which a lot of people don't
don't really do anymore whether they're
in recovery or not and I think you know
just showing that you actually love
yourself enough to take a chance put the
drugs down put the alcohol down and try
to work something that will help you
lead you in the right direction you know
with the clients that you work with
what's the difference between those that
actually make strides and those that
don't I think the ones that that really
make the strides are the ones that like
are just so like persistent and
dedicated they put it in their schedule
as like an appointment like it's like
they're it's like part of their day like
they know it's like a doctor's
appointment or not missing a workout and
they're just they're wired that way
they're driven and they have seen
something I think a lot of it it's just
like in recovery like when you're
training somebody like when you start to
see some success it snowballs and helps
you really keep your eye on the prize
and keep going towards the bigger goals
and you know the ones they just they
don't give up it's a sheer determination
and that will to to win and just you
know follow instructions and if I say
hey you know don't eat this or layoff
this or hey you gotta exercise three to
four times a week the people that do
that it works like and the people that
don't it doesn't I mean it just come on
it's gotta be here there's got to be a
better answer than that no there's I
mean yeah no I know you know and you
know and I mean that people always they
want like a magic pill or there's
something listen like if you do what I
say and you work out three to five times
a week and you keep your calories in
check
I mean you will lose weight like that's
just I mean unless you have some you
know metabolic disease or die whatever
something that's uncontrollable but for
the most
general population you will I mean yeah
all right so I'm at home in my mom's
basement I'm listening to this podcast
I'm smoking too many blunts hidden you
know Wendy's a little too often I know I
need to like work out a little bit maybe
I should lay off the weed and maybe not
go out with my buddy so much but like I
don't know man it's not that bad like
how do you connect with that person like
how do you jump-start somebody who's
kind of in that place where yeah it's
not going in a good direction but
they're not like going to jail right
they're not getting pulled over with one
headlight it hasn't hit a flashpoint in
that way but this is a person who you
know could benefit from making a few
lifestyle changes I mean I think it's
just asking them some questions asking
them are you happy with the way your
life is and like honestly are you happy
like and then you know some people yeah
I'm happy Mike so you're telling me
sitting in your mom's basement when
you're 35 years old smoking blunts you
know listening to Tupac and eating
cheeseburgers makes you happy every day
which there's nothing wrong with Tupac
by the way but and then like you just
start to unlace things right and then
like you're able to ask him some tough
questions and again you got to build
relate I mean I build a relationship
with some of these people that you talk
to I mean you can't just walk in and say
stuff like that but you just kind of
come at him from a loving place and just
show that you're awfully care and be
like well you know what if I told you
that if we went for a 20-minute walk
that you might feel a little bit better
and um and then you just kind of like
they might be like no I'm not gonna feel
them like why don't you just try like
what do you have to lose right and they
try it and nine times out of ten they're
gonna feel better right as long as they
you know don't have any injuries or
anything and then you just kind of build
steps off of that I mean I think it's
just like you know the 12 steps right
you just accomplished one thing and then
you just keep going and keep layering
things on top of it momentum is so
important yeah and I think and I think a
lot of times these kids are people who
however old they are that they just
don't know any other way so like they've
they've been taught that
whatever way they're doing is the only
way whether it's the friends around them
whether it's what they listen to or what
they watch and just being able to show
them there is another path and whatever
that path looks like I mean it's got to
come out of like love and care you don't
want to I would never go in and just
start talking down to a kid but I would
definitely ask him some tough questions
because it allows him to have some open
dialogue to be able to answer in an
honest way hopefully oh how he feels
about his life and you know because you
get start to get in the unwrapped peel
the onion back a little bit and then
sure enough this kid tells ya oh man I'm
really not happy like you know tell you
the truth like I broke up with my
girlfriend a year ago and I haven't been
able to you know get over it I've been
in my parents basement because I lost my
job six months ago and I can't afford to
eat healthy so I eat Wendy's and I smoke
weed because I don't want to kill myself
I mean you hear some deep stuff
sometimes when you peel the onion back
it's not always what it appears and
that's why I say go in and you just ask
them to start you just ask some tough
questions and hopefully if they're at a
spot where they're willing to answer you
can really you can really get some work
done yeah lead with empathy and it's you
know you coming from where you've come
from you can create that bridge probably
a lot easier than most people oh yeah
being able to relate to them I mean
relatability is is the spice of life I
think you know many things if not all
and just being only like you listen like
I mean I and I also would just say like
listen if you if you think I don't know
everything but I know some things and I
know I get where you're at I know I was
the kid who was suicidal was hopeless
was slinging drugs you know left and
right eaten you know fast food all the
time and I had no hope but if it wasn't
for somebody helping me you know find a
new path I wouldn't be where I am today
and I'm just trying to do the same for
you yeah yeah it's it's the person who's
willing to help but it's also timing
yeah that person showed up at a moment
where you actually had the willingness
to you know take the Lifeline had you
been had that guy come across your path
a year earlier you might have told him
to [ __ ] off so yeah it's again it goes
back to that kind of divine providence
yeah and timing and timing is everything
and and so I just
you know and I think that my cellmate he
didn't come at me like you need to
change it was just like come on like
just kept nudging me kept like tapped me
on the shoulder kind of like my client
who wanted me to come to church he
didn't like wasn't like you need to come
to church you're going to hell he was
like you know if you want to come the
church you're more than welcome we go to
Chipotle afterwards like yeah I don't
eat Chipotle but and then he just kept
being like are you sure he's sure and
then finally when I was ready he hadn't
pushed me away he just gently tapped me
that I was able to be like alright well
let me try this thing out that's the
same way with a lot of these kids like I
don't lead with you better stop doing
drugs I lead with questions and I lead
with you know I don't have all the
answers and I'm not here to tell you
what to do I'm not your father but this
is my story and I was your age not long
ago and I'm here to tell you there's a
better way out if you're willing to meet
me there mm-hmm
what do you think is the thing that
holds most people back I mean I think
it's many but I think one is just they
just don't believe in themselves and
when stuff gets hard they quit because
life does get hard I mean first for me
to say life gets easy when you stop
using drugs is it it just couldn't be
far from the truth but you know they
just don't see a better way and when
they see they they want to get better
and then you know the slightest thing
will happen and they'll [ __ ] this like
my life's not better like I've only I've
stopped using drugs to to only two days
you know and they want they want
everything to happen like right now and
then you know also just like there's
sort their environment I think kids like
I was saying earlier part of the problem
is the pot right I think in a lot of
cases right and many but also the the
like environment of like that's what all
you do is ride around and smoke pot with
your friends is like a huge problem
because then like you're leaving your
community right we've talked about the
importance of community and then you're
all of a sudden being forced to leave
that community and go somewhere else
where kids now being in the age of
social media where we've you know the
ability of having face-to-face
interaction is slowly fading it's hard
for them to meet new friends so it's
better than their minds to go back and
hang out with the same friends and try
to maybe not smoke pot but of course we
know
that if do that long enough now the odds
are against you that you'll stay away
from it
and it's hard it's hard to be 15 16 17
years old you know and when you create
community around something like smoking
pot it's tough to break out of that you
know your social life is everything and
you know in a social media culture where
everyone's being judged you know behind
their back and to their face you know
through Instagram and snapchat and the
like the the levels of anxiety and
stress that people in this age bracket
are experiencing I think are
unprecedented I think that's
contributing to more and more checking
out and drug use I mean yeah I mean I
watched simon Sinek was on Tom bill used
impact Theory or healthier years ago
talking about giving the kid a cell
phone it at a young age was like I mean
I think he compared it to alcohol or
something but he was just saying how
kids can they can if they're depressed
they can just check out and go to their
phones right and I think you know we're
seeing that a lot now with kids on
snapchat and Instagram and and in a
matter of seconds kids can get jealous
envious competitive comparative however
you want to call up I just pulling out
their phone looking on Instagram so can
adults yeah well yeah yeah yeah yeah no
I know truck yeah but you know and so
you can just see like that person has a
better body or man that person just
bought a jet or a new car there were all
those people that I thought were my
friends are now at a party that I'm not
at right and they told me they were
doing something else right yeah and
that's that's hard for kids that's like
a way of like I mean one of my clients
does something a way of bullying now is
for that to happen that very reason they
put all these they put a picture up of
all these kids and they don't tag the
one person who wasn't there or you know
what and if in the picture and the kid
sees it and they're like you know what
the heck and it's for everybody to see
and and as much as technology is great I
I so I think it's Kamiya an awesome tool
I think so many people like you said we
use it as ways to compete with people
and but I think there's I mean is that
there's a there's obviously silver
lining and everything and that's why
there's people you know like
like you and others that you know have a
strong influence and are able to be
authentic and genuine and show how you
can use social media in a positive way
and not in a way to tear other people
down and bully people or you know be a
snake oil salesman which there's a lot
of that too right yeah and it's hard
it's hard to divine you know fact from
fiction and kind of find your true north
through all of this and when you're
young and impressionable and insecure
and afraid you know you're you're cannon
fodder for you know being manipulated
and and you know all the sort of darker
sides of what social media is presenting
right now yeah and you just don't know
where it's gonna head and you don't know
what angle it's gonna take but I mean
it's not gonna think it's going away so
how can kids and adults and everybody
else affected by it you know manage it I
think it's the tools because I mean for
people to say they're never gonna check
Instagram again or whatever I mean
they're they're not telling the truth I
mean I used on that I mean um you know
it's part of our it's part of our lives
and I think if you're a young person you
know the answer isn't no cell phone like
this is the vocabulary of how this
generation communicates like you can't
deprive them of becoming you know
proficient in that language but there
has to be boundaries and there has to be
analog experiences to counterbalance
that to craft healthy sense of
self-esteem and purpose that isn't
reliant upon the reactionary you know
proclivities of some you know a bunch of
teenagers who are you know all swirling
with crazy hormones that are making them
do things that you know when they're
thirty they'll regret yeah and I just
think goes back to how are we dealing
with the stressors and the thing that
bug us out I mean if we get if we get
bugged out on Instagram or Facebook by
something something somebody says that
we saw I mean how could we manage that
stress in a healthy way and it's not you
know drugs and alcohol it's you know
surrounding yourself with great people
it's having mentors people you can lean
on and you know we're
get out and eat and smart and if and if
your kids you know making sure that
you're hanging out with people that have
like common futures and not coming past
that was one of the hard things for me
was I was like man I've known XY and Z
people for so long but it's like you
know do you want to be somebody who
you're 50 years old looking back at your
life being like you know man I wish I
would have changed my friends and taking
more risks on myself and Here I am like
sitting in a bar by myself you know just
drinking because you know I didn't
really work on myself or change my
environment or you want to be that same
person at 50 being like man I'm so
thankful that you know I did the hard
thing I sucked it up and stayed in on
weekends for for a little while until I
built a new network of friends and now
here I am with a family and we're happy
and and it's a lot easier said than done
but I mean those are definitely two
different paths they now love it later
yeah you know what I mean
but that's tough in an instant
gratification culture where everyone
wants what they want immediately it
doesn't work that way we all want it now
and it's like we even it makes my job my
profession people we want I mean I'm
seeing it a lot with people with the
calories people are like well how many
calories did I burn on I'm like well
there's a lot more that goes into
exercise than just the calories I mean
if your strength training it's you know
the benefit the benefits will be a lot
longer endure than if it is just that
single workout for calories and but it's
because we have the access on our
watches to see instantly you know what
our heart rate is how many calories we
burn you know text messages and so we've
almost like correlated that in other
areas of our lives too
it's crazy man what are your your
buddies doing now the ones that your
Ryder dive buddies from back in the day
I think you know some have clean cleaned
up and there's something I haven't you
know and but but you've put out your
your it's not like they're still your
inner circle no not at all I'm not in
but you stayed in that come in this in
the same community yeah I mean but I
just had to shut it off and there was a
while for a while I would hang out with
them and I just it got to a point where
I just I didn't have as much in common
like I was about like eating like you
know like boiled chicken and broccoli
for dinner or something I'm just making
that something like that right and and
they were you know getting ready go to
the bar I want
- nah I wanted to be able to go for you
know Iran and you know date so it just
like I didn't have I didn't align with
him like before it was like we all just
did drugs together we're now her it came
to the point where I was on a healthier
lifestyle and I wanted to help you know
not only myself but be able to help
other people and I just had to start out
aligning myself with people that wanted
that and I started just reading write I
started reading books and you know like
the one guy I know who's been on here
whose books I loved is John Gordon I
just started reading like yeah yeah yeah
he's the dude he's the man he's got lots
of books yeah he turns those things out
like I don't know how he does that man
but his I mean they're so small I mean
but his books like they're simple
they're easy to read so I started
reading like you know I stuff like that
and I started reading Gary B we talked
about and I just you know start to learn
about that either the type of person
that you want to be the type of people
you should be hanging out with or how to
treat people and it was all kind of
different than the drug culture I had
immersed myself into which was you know
a bit be a bit more you know challenging
for myself and I just I really I
commemorate like the people that did all
that stuff because they'd wrote those
books because personal development for
me has been huge and it's being able to
meet people and just like you ask the
right questions and it's just been a
huge huge help for me with with
everything in my life what's the main
thing that you want people to take away
from your story I mean the main thing I
tell people is to always focus on how
far they've come and not how far they
have to go because there was a lot of
times where I wanted to quit and I just
remembered what Eric did for me in jail
the things he said to me and I also
remembered all the times I'd failed as a
kid all the times I was unhappy and
stressed and depressed and I didn't want
to ever feel like that again and I knew
that if I went the other way like if I
went back to doing drugs or eating
pizzas and cheesesteaks and all that
stuff that there was a good possibility
I was gonna end up that same kid again
and I just had to keep telling myself
that and and sure enough the more I kept
telling myself that and more was like
second nature to just know that like
okay this is
right this is wrong this is good this is
bad like you know go to this side of the
street and don't go on the other side
and it just and be good because a lot of
people they because they want the
results quick and it's not gonna happen
quick like it took me I mean I've been
going out at 10 years and I still feel
like I don't have it all figured out you
know I'm only 31 years old and it took a
while for me to get this fitness thing
together where I was able to to work out
and you know it didn't just it wasn't
just like yesterday I just always
haven't like I think I'm gonna like
start going on podcasts and write books
it was like I not even well I don't even
want to do like I didn't want to I
didn't want to write another book but
you know I felt like I just there was
something deeper calling me and it was
my passion for recovery but not like so
so much in the like talking about like
sobriety it was more like okay like it
was more like what kind of tools and
tips can I have for when you do get into
recovery on how you can like really
thrive like how you can be healthy again
and that's why I just I really wanted to
to just be more open about sharing my
message of hope and encouragement so
just help people you know focus on being
better versions of themselves 31 3 books
your felt like I got sober that when you
when you said 31 I was like [ __ ] now you
got like 10 years under your belt like
I'm that's amazing man you have a bright
future ahead of you my friend I mean I
appreciate the kind words and it's been
an honor an honor to talk to you I mean
I've been following you for quite some
time and just to be able to kind of just
sit in the room you know with my name on
the wall there it's just it's really
humbling well it's cool it's uh it's
been an honor to talk to you your story
is amazing the trajectory is incredible
super inspiring and it's just proof
positive of what can happen when you get
sober and you take stock of your life
and responsibility for your actions and
your decisions and you begin to pay it
forward and you develop a you know
spiritual life and a physically healthy
life like across the board all of these
things can congeal to craft this life
that you never thought that you wanted
or knew that you wanted
to be this you know beacon of hope and
light for so many people out there it's
really a beautiful thing yeah I
appreciate that I mean if just as long
as you know I'm staying true to who I am
in genuine and that's all that counts
you know and just being able to really
be there for people and never forget
where I came from and I mean that was
always the big thing is I just I mean I
have friends that's that reach out to me
they're like a celebrity now I'm like no
I'm not I'm just a person who I'm just
trying to help people I'm not a
celebrity I'm not anybody who's better
than anybody else I'm not smart I just I
just want to really just help people and
you know share my story with as many
people as possible cuz this is it it's a
huge problem I mean what people are
dying from drug overdoses down the car
accidents I mean it's not like it's a
small thing anymore so with that in mind
let's close it down with some words of
wisdom or some some hope for the person
out there who's listening to this who
who is stuck and in that cycle where
they feel like they just can't quit I
mean I really would just say just just
not to give up on yourself and to just
know that life will be better on the
other side of the tunnel and you know if
you're standing in that dark tunnel
right now and you can't see light I
think it's just important to have faith
and just know that like faith is being
able to see what's not seen and that
light will be at the end of the tunnel
if you keep putting one foot in front of
the other like one day at a time one
week at a time one month at a time
because you know what's behind you
you know if you turn around and go back
to that dark place you know where that
gets you so why not tries to try
something different and just to know
that like you're not a [ __ ] you just
[ __ ] up I think a lot of people kind
of stated they label themselves as a
[ __ ] I mean I hear it a lot I'm like
no you're not you just best admits you
made mistakes it's okay we all make
mistakes what did you learn from it and
I think it's important for people to
understand that like they're not a
failure to not identify with your
actions right because you did these
things it doesn't necessarily mean
that's who you are you know and I think
that's a big one
because you do you think you know how
could I be this person who's constantly
making this these terrible choices I
must be a awful human being and it's
like no you're you're
just your drug addict or your an
alcoholic these are not who you really
are right you're suffering from a
condition that is compelling you to make
choices that are not in your best
interest and that are alienating
everyone around you but the good news is
we can fix that right right so I love
what you said and I would just
supplement it with these words which is
if you feel like you're in a hopeless
state that there is always hope and you
need not ever drink or use again if you
don't want to there is help available to
you and faith is super important as you
mentioned but also works are as well you
need to raise your hand and ask for help
you need to get over whatever fear you
have around asking for help addicts and
alcoholics they want to just solve the
problem by themselves yeah I know as
somebody who unsuccessfully attempted
that it's hard to do it alone most
people can't
I couldn't it's okay to ask for help and
I think you'll find if you if you extend
yourself in that regard there are a lot
of people around who'd be more than
willing to help you and there is a path
forward and you know as somebody who's
been or you know a part of this
community for a long time I've seen
lives change in such dramatic fashion it
would just blow your mind I mean the
stuff of cinema it's crazy and the life
as we said earlier the life that you
didn't even think that you wanted is out
there waiting for you it's not the end
it is the beginning couldn't have said
it better myself so thanks for spending
some time with me today man thanks for
having me yeah I care about these issues
a lot and I really love how you carry
the message man so much love and success
to you the new book is called the heart
of recovery it's out March 15 march 12
March 12 we store soon man you can find
that on Amazon and what else man are you
doing any like public events where
people can come and see you or shake
your hand or no I mean I really don't
have much budget playing Marilyn just
going back to Maryland that I don't know
whether I book tour or anything like I
wanted to and I talked to my my
publicist and he was just like I mean I
we kind of want I want it but I mean
again people are buying books on
I know and I just like I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna retire being an author I
didn't I didn't like this book isn't
gonna make me a ton of money I don't
expect it to but if it does great but
it's just part of my message I guess you
know I still my trainer I love training
people and just hopefully the book is
just supplements you know that to help
people know that there's there's tools
out there and there's different ways you
know you might not have it all figured
out there's a lot of people that have
they've tried and have had some success
with it and I just hope that they pick
it up if people want to connect with you
Doug buffs calm and at Doug underscore
Bob's yeah Instagram those are the best
places yeah all right dude any last
words how do you feel I feel great mass
has been an honor this is definitely
worth worth worth the the East the West
Coast trip all right cool are you gonna
go see Amy I saw her yesterday yeah well
we uh we walked around Santa Monica and
and then we should let me train you in
person she's like no only on skype so I
went to I went to her place I wish I saw
her little home gym and put together a
pull-up bar for that she doesn't think
she'll ever be able to use but I said
you know won't get there all right good
deal man all right well come back and
talk to me again sometime
amen absolutely all right peace Lance
[Music]